Herkese merhaba hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
Bugün sizi benim onlarca yıl önce
yaşadığım bir çelişkiye anlatarak
başlamak istiyorum üniversiteden Önceki
yıllarda benim önümde İki Yol vardı
kendimi bir yol ayrımında hissettim
Doktor olmak ya da mühendis olmak Bak
eğer Doktor olursam Belki bir hastayı
kurtaramam ve büyük bir vicdan azabı
hissederim diye korkarak mühendisliki
mesleğini seçti fakat Daha sonrasında
öğrendim ki aslında Mühendislik
mesleğinde bir hata yaparak yüzlerce
binlerce kişiyi aynı anda
öldürebilirsiniz Yani sorumluluktan
kaçmak
Bu bir yolu yok gerçekten Belki de bu
sorumluluğa en güzel örnek 2015 yılında
İzmit Körfez Geçiş Köprüsü nde yaşanan
hayat korkmasıdır bu şantiyede kendini
sorumlu hisseden Japon mühendis kişi
köprüde intihar etmişti bu hüzünlü
hikaye sadece inşaat mühendislerinin
köprülerde riskli olduğunu göstermiyor
Elbette İnşaat Mühendisliği İngilizce'de
Civil engineer yani medeniyet
mühendisliği dir medeniyetin
altyapısıyla ilgili Burada gördüğünüz
bütün yapıları Biz tasarlıyoruz ve İnşa
ediyoruz hayatımızda nasıl işi olduğunu
size anlatmak için belki de örnek
verebilirim diyelim ki sabah kalktınız
ilk yaptığımız şey yüzünüzü yıkamak
mutlu açtığınızda Akansu borulardan
inşaat mühendislerinin sayesinde geliyor
inşaat mühendislerinin yaptığı barajlar
ne diyor daha sonra lavabodan giden
kirli atık su yine kanalizasyon
sistemiyle Bizim sayemizde daha sonra
arabanıza bildiğiniz yada toplu taşıma
işyerinize giderken geçtiğiniz yollara
İnşaat Mühendisleri yapıyor Köprüler
tüneller havalimanları kıyı Liman ve iş
yerinde çalıştığınız Tabii ki ofisler
sonra tekrar evinize gelip rahat
yatağınızda yaptığımız evler Elbette
İnşaat Mühendisleri tarafından ve işin
ilginç tarafı İnşaat Mühendisliği
insanlık kadar eski bir meslek
insanlığın ilk yerleşimleri yine
Anadolu'da Bu da büyük bir raslantı
Göbeklitepe bundan 12 bin yıl önce ilk
inşaatın başladığı yer ve bundan sonra
belki Muhtemelen en eski inşaat planı da
milattan önce 1800'lü yıllara geliyor
aynı yıllarda yaşayan Babil kralı
O da beni sorumluluk ve vicdan üzerine
yasaları var bunun 229. maddesi inşa
ettiği bina yıkılıp sahibini öldürürse
inşa inşaatı yapan da öldürülür
Bu bir sonraki 230. madde Eğer bina ev
sahibinin çocuğunu öldürürse inşaatı
yapanın çocuğu öldürülür gördüğünüz gibi
sorumluluklarla içiçe bir meslek
bu masrafın ihtiyaçlar hiyerarşisinde
arkamda gördüğünüz gibi traimit var ve
bu piramitin aşağıdaki en geniş tabanlı
kısmı bizim en çok ihtiyacımız olan şey
bunların başında da temel fizyolojik
ihtiyaçlar barınma su ulaşım güvenlik
gibi konular geliyor ki İnşaat
Mühendisliği Bu konularla ilgili
çalışmalar yapıyor ev Muhtemelen
bilmediğiniz bir gerçek var Türkiye
inşaat sektöründe son 10 yıldır dünya
ikincisi birincisi için bu benim için
bayağı etkileyici bir istatistik bizim
ülkemizdeki Müteahhitler dünyadaki en
büyük 250 müteahhit arasında 44 tanesi
Türk firması w126 farklı ülkede 48 yılda
10000 projenin toplam maliyeti 400
milyar dolardan fazla Ayrıca inşaat
sektörü her dönemde ülke ekonomisinin
lokomotif pozisyonunda
İyi o zaman şu soruyu sorabiliriz
Kendimizi nasıl oluyor da Türkiye'de
depremlerde bunca kayıplar yaşanabiliyor
Bunun cevabı Belki de bu fotoğrafta
gizli acaba aranızda cevabı görebilen
var mı bu cevapları gelmeden önce Belki
de şapkamızı çıkartıp önümüze koyup
ciddi ciddi düşünmemiz lazım Nerede hata
yapıyoruz Ee sebeplere geleceğim ama
size bir kaç bilgi vermek istiyorum
mesela 2004 yılında bir kurban bayramı
akşamı O hiç bir Deprem olmadan yıkılan
Zümrüt Apartmanı hepiniz hatırlıyorsunuz
dur kendi ağırlığı altında yıkıldı hala
devam davası devam ediyor kolon
kesildiğine dair bir bilgi var ama emin
değiliz biz Eğer günümüze gelirsek
Elazığ depremi da
bu Geçtiğimiz günlerde oldu burada
birçok Mina görüyorsunuz ama bunlardan
bir tanesi yıkılmış acaba bu binanın
yıkılmasındaki sebep neydi bunları size
maddeler halinde anlatacağım ama
birazcık depremlere bakalım bu depremler
nasıl oluşuyor niçin oluşuyor Anadolu
güneyden kuzeye doğru ilerleyen ara
plakasını sıkıştırma sıyla Batıya doğru
hareket ediyor ve bizim ülkemizde iki
büyük fay hattı var Kuzey Anadolu ve
Doğu Anadolu fay hatları bunu hayal
etmek için parmaklarınızın arasında
birer Limon çekirdeği tuttuğunuzu
düşünün sıktığınız zaman nasıl fırlarsa
Arap plakasını çarpmasıyla Anadolu Ege
doğru hareket ediyor ve senede iki buçuk
santimetre ilerliyor bu tırnağımızın
Büyüme hızına eş değer veren aynı
zamanda da sıkıştı için faydalar
arasında biriken enerjide formasyonla
birikiyor ve birden kayıyor
o zaman Depremler Oluyor sonra yine
birikmeye başlıyor takip tekrar
kalıncaya kadar Baran afad'ın yakın
zamanda açıkladı bilgiye göre son 120
yıldır 13000 deprem ülkemizde olmuş
değişik büyüklüklerde 86.000
vatandaşımız vefat etmiş ve 603 Bin Yapı
yıkılmış artık biz buna bir yerde dur
demek zorundayız
Evet Ee yine büyük depremleri harita
üzerinde koyarsak Biraz önce söylediğin
fay hatlarıyla bunların üst üste
bindiğini görüyorsunuz Bu fay hatları
üzerinde Elazığ davara İstanbul'da var
İstanbul defa Aslında depremlere çok da
yabancı bir şehrimiz değil 500 lü
yıllardan beri Ayasofya'nın hasar
görmesinden 1509 da ki Küçük Kıyamet
diye anılan olaylara kadar her 353
yüzyılda ya da 18 yıl aralıklı olanda
büyük depremler olmuş İstanbul'da 1509
da Ahşap binalara geçilmesi Osmanlı
tarafından düşünülmüş ve buradan bizim
gördüğümüze göre depremlerin bir sonraki
depremin büyüklüğü ve zamanını şu anki
bilimsel verilerle elde edemiyoruz ama
o nerede olacağını biliyoruz Çünkü bu
Türkiye deprem tehlike haritasında bile
gördüğünüz kırmızı bölgeler farlarla
birleşiyorlar ve buralarda deprem
olacağını biliyoruz bazı kişiler çıkıp
şurada Fayat üzerinde deprem olacak
derse bu deprem önceden bilmek değil Biz
Bu bilgiye zaten sahibiz İstanbul'da 5.8
büyüklüğünde olan Yakın zamandaki
depremde bize bunları hatırlattı
Dilerseniz size birkaç bilimsel bilgi
vermek istiyorum deprem büyüklükleri
ikişer ikişer arttığında Aslında ortaya
çıkan enerji 1000 kat artıyor Mesela 5.8
ve 7.8 arasında ya da dörtlü altı
büyüklük arasında 1000 kat enerji farkı
var 7 büyüklüğündeki bir deprem 20
milyar kilogram dinamitin patlaması
eşdeğer enerji açığa çıkartıyor ve bu
mesela New York şehrinin bir yıllık
bütün ısınma ihtiyacını karşılıyor
İstanbul'da beklenen 7.2 ile 5.8
arasındadır Bulgari
bu olan TL 126 kat fark var yani son
deprem bu beklenen 7.2 nin Aslında 120
altıda birini açığa çıkarttı şimdi bu
fotoğrafı tekrar dönersek belki size
birkaç kritik bilgi söyleyebilirim
inşaat mühendisi olarak neler en çok
etkiliyor Öncelikle eski tasarım Çünkü
1998-2000 7 w2019 deprem yönetmelikleri
geçmişteki büyük depremlerden
öğrendiğimiz verileri içeriyor lar ve
daha fazla deprem kuvvetine göre
tasarlama mı istiyorlar bundan önceki
binalar Yaklaşık dört kat daha düşük
deprem kuvvetlerine karşı tasarlanıyor
dua yapısal müdahaleler kolon kesme gibi
bunlar etkili ve bana sorarsanız Kiriş
kolon bağlantılarında ki etki eksikliği
de son yönetmeliklerde bulunan fakat
Eskiden bulunmayan bir etken buradaki
gördüğünüz kolon ve Kiriş bağlan
Bu depremde eritre yoksa mafsallı aşıyor
ve sanki bir kuklayı iplerinden
bıraktığınızda binanın çökmesi gibi bina
çöküyor mesela arkamda bütün kolon
kirişler güzel hiç bir hasar yok ama
düğüm noktaları patlamış ve bütün bina
yıkılmış perde duvar bulunmaması başka
bir eksiklik yeterlilikle eski binalarda
Burada gördüğünüz gibi sadece kolonlar
var ama perde duvarlar daha uzun
betonarme elemanlar ve bunlar depreme
deprem sırasında çok fazla yük taşıma
kapasitesine sahip Yapı zemin etkileşimi
çok önemli bir parametre insanlar
binaları ayrı ayrı düşünüyorlar ama
zemin ve bina bir bütündür zayıf
zeminlere yapılan binalar gerçekten daha
kötü performans gösteriyorlar eski
yönetmeliklere Uyan yeni binalar ve
alkali silika reaksiyonu donatıların
paslanması yine örnek sayılabilir birer
bu zamanlarda belki Sizinde çok
duyduğunuz bir fikre var üç müteahhitin
binaları çökmüş birisi vakitli benim
kumların çakılların Diyormuş bir tanesi
Mahvoldum gitti çimento olalım diyormuş
birisi de iyi ki donatı koymamış Imm
Yoksa benim de donatıları gidecek demiş
Tabii ki bu insan hayatı bizim için çok
önemli ama bir diğer faktörde yapıdaki
düzensizlikler binada bizi düzgün
çerçeveler oluşturmak istiyoruz ismi
yönlerinde bu şekilde gördüğünüz gibi
birbirine binen kirişler ve düzensiz bir
taşıma sistemi de hasara yol açabiliyor
E peki ne yapacağız yapabileceğimiz
şeyler var Bunlardan birincisi binamız
sağlam mı diye araştırmamız lazım bizi
mutlu de geliştirdiğimiz anket vardı bir
takım ön eleme kriterleri var bunlara
göre bina stoğu g
bu çok riskli az riskli ayırt
edebiliyoruz Güçlendirme ve son
yıllardaki Sismik izolasyon bir
alternatif burada arkamda gördüğünüz iki
Yapı Aslında tümüyle aynı ve aşağıdan
aynı depreme maruz kalıyorlar ama sağ
taraftaki nin altında Sismik izolasyon
var bina ile zemin arasına bir izolatör
koyuyoruz ve yer sallandığında bina
havada asılı kalıyor Elazığ depremindeki
Devlet Hastanesi de bu şekilde izole
edildiği için hasar görmedi ve ayrıca
Müzeler tarihi yapılar hastanelerde bu
uygulandığı zaman deprem sırasında
hastalar ya da kıymetli vazolar
sallanmıyor lar ve depremden hasar
görmüyorlar bu
Ben bunu bir örnek yakın zamanda benim
danışmanlığını yaptığım Batman'daki
hasankeyf'teki Zeynel Bey türbesi
taşınması türbe depreme karşı çok
zayıftı ve Batman ikinci derece deprem
bölgesi yeni gittiği yerde zaten
kaldırdığımız için onu Sismik
izolatörler üzerine koyduk ve deprem
olsa dahi artık Zeynel Bey türbesi hasar
görmeyecek ülkemizde depremler oluyor
Sadece biz mi Bunlardan hasar görüyoruz
hayır Mesela Japonya'da 1995 yılında
olan 7.2 büyüklüğündeki depremde 6500
kişi can verdi Bundan Sadece dört buçuk
yıl sonra 17ağustos 99 depreminin belki
yaşadığınız vardır aramızda 7.5
büyüklüğünde ve onsekizbin vatandaşımızı
burada kaybettik Yine yakın zamanda daha
küçük bir deprem 6.8 ama 41 can aldı biz
artık bu büyüklükteki depremlerde Can
bu vermemiz lazım bina tasarımlarında
performansa dayalı olarak orta hasar
görmesi beklenebilir ama yıkılmaması
lazım büyük depremlerde yıkılmayan orta
büyüklükteki depremlerde az hasar gören
binalar tasarlıyoruz Evet geçmişten beri
bizim bildiğimiz dört tane element
vardır Bunlar toprak hava su ve ateş biz
inşaat mühendislerinin başı hepsiyle
belada buradaki toprak olarak belki
depremleri düşünebilirsiniz ama Toprak
kaymaları taş düşmeleri suyla ilgili
olarak Seller büyük yağmurlar bu
Fırtınalar hortumlar ve belki Tsunami
der mesela Japonya'dan bir fotoğraf
sular çekildikten sonra Koskoca gemi
binanın üzerinde kalmış Ayrıca
yanardağlar yine depreme sebep
olabiliyor ve büyük yangınlar bir
bu sonsuz al ya da yakın zamanda bütün
bir kıta yanıyor şort Peki ne yapacağız
Ben sizi umutsuzluğa kaptırmak
istemiyorum Hatta tam tersine umutlarımı
yüksek gelişen teknoloji ile artık
elimizde çok daha güzel aletler var
bilgisayar simülasyonları sayesinde her
binanın her köşesinde ne kadar kuvvetli
oluştuğunu biliyoruz ve buna göre
tasarımlarımızı çok güzel yapıyoruz
yapısal sağlıklı izleme denilen bir
teknikle binaları sensörler takıyoruz
Aynı bizim vücudumuzda olduğu gibi
sensörler binanın bir yerinde sorun
olduğunda hissediyorlar Mesela yüzünüzde
bir sorun olduğunda nasıl ağrıyorsa
binanın bir köşesinde Eğer bir
deformasyon zorlanma varsa biz artık onu
hissedebiliyoruz bir yerinde yangın
çıktıysa bunu önceden fark edebiliyoruz
bölümümüzde bir sürü fırsatlar açılıyor
gelişen elektronik Yapay Zeka robotlar
bu ve zeki yapılara yol açıyorlar ve 21.
yüzyılda daha çok göreceğiniz
sürdürülebilirlik kavramı var çünkü
kirli Sanayi ve endüstri artık dünyayı
yaşanmaz hale getirdi giderek daha çok
güneş enerjisi alternatif malzemeleri
kullanacağız İnşaat mühendisliğinde de
böyle Üstün süper malzemeler buluyoruz
mesela nokarbon tipleri Siz de
duymuşsunuzdur karbon fiberler çelikten
2 3 kat daha kuvvetli ve size yeni bir
üstün süper malzemeden bahsedeceğim
bilmiyorum aranızda tahmin ediniz
olabilecek mi bu malzemeyi üretmek için
fabrika ya gerek yok betondan beş kat
daha hafif çelikten 15 kat daha hafif
bu tümüyle güneş enerjisi kullanılarak
üretiliyor herhangi bir hammadde
vermenize gerek yok hammaddesini tümüyle
havadan alıyor Tahmin edeniniz var mı
bu ahşap tahta diyerek V elementd
ediyorlar olarak ahşap malzemeler
gerçekten havadaki karbondioksit
oksijeni atıp karbonlu alıp gövdesini
oluşturuyor beton kadar kuvvetli Eğer
ağırlıkla orantılar sanız Çelik ve
başarıdan çelikten daha bile kuvvetli
olan bir malzeme Osmanlı'da bahsetmiştik
günümüzde Amerika'da ve Kanada'da
yapıların 100'de 95'i ahşaptan yapılıyor
ahşap kullanın kullanımında Belki de
Yangına karşı zayıf diye
düşünebilirsiniz size çok meşhur bir
fotoğraf göstereceğim yangından sonra
çekilmiş bir fotoğraf Burada gördüğünüz
iki Çelik eleman 600 dereceyi geçtiği
zaman yumuşak bir hamur kıvamına geliyor
ve taşıyıcılığının yitiriyor Burada
gördüğünüz donatılar çöken döşemeye ait
ve onlarda taşırlar mı getir
bu ama şurada gördüğünüz İnci'de kalmış
olsa ahşap Kiriş yangında dışarıdan
içeriye doğru yanmasına rağmen hala
taşıyıcılığında devam ettire bilmiş O
yüzden ben Yangınlarda binanın çökmesi
Önemli belki ikiz kuleleri hatırlarsınız
ahşap Bu açıdan da faydalı bir malzeme
21. yüzyılda biraz küçük pislik
olaylardan bahsedeyim artık bina larımız
kendi enerjisi Üretir ve doğayla uyumlu
hale gelecekler ve ileride uzaya
gittiğimiz zaman da belki Mars'a
yerleşmek mümkün Mars'taki binalar da
yine İnşaat Mühendisleri yapacaklar Eğer
siz İkile tabletten Mars'ta binalara
kadar bir yolculuğa çıkarttım
doktorlarla başladığımız bu vicdan ve
sorumluluk hissini Eğer hepimiz taşırsak
aynı Doktorlar gibi bizde Hayat
kurtarabiliriz Mühendisler idareciler
Çiftçiler doğru kararları alırlarsa
çok soğuk ve vicdan sahibi olurlarsa
bunu sağlayabiliriz bir inşaat ve
Aslında medeniyet mühendisi olarak hamur
abi yasasından uzayda yaşamaya doğru
teşhis edilen hastalıklar dan Depreme
dayanıklı altyapıya kadar her alanda
vicdanımızın dışında hepimizin
sorumluluklarını yerine getirmesi
umuduyla teşekkür ederiz sağ ol